rand how you doing lately man you've  been you've been going through a lot i  just want to check in on you  oh yeah i'm i'm doing totally fine  what's uh what  what's the candle for this oh it's just  the flame in the void it's the  mental image i used to throw all of my  fears and worries and passions into  until i feel absolutely  nothing it's really nice  that's cool man that's cool because i  just wanted to like pop in and say that  like  you know the fate of the world rests in  your hands you're like the most  important person in the universe and  like  everyone's counting on you and i just  want rand sounds great you know there's  also therapy this is working pretty good  for me  so far so  [Music]  you